but first moments ago California
Governor Gavin Newsome ordering everyone
in the state to stay at home and it's
called a stay safe order or something
Jeff Paul in the West Coast newsroom has
all the details Jeff yeah and this is
just coming down the wire here it's
officially called a stay at home order
and essentially the the idea here is to
keep people from mingling from being out
together and doing things that aren't
absolutely necessary now under this
order which goes into effect tonight
things that will stay open are
essentials like gas stations pharmacy
grocery stores things that provide food
banks launder bat laundry service things
that might not be able to do under this
order especially here in the city of LA
because mayor Garcetti announced
something similar a little bit earlier
today really you shouldn't be going to
work here in LA unless it's one of these
essential services and really shouldn't
be out visiting anybody at a hospital
right now because that could put you
further at risk one other thing that the
governor announced on this was that
hospitalizations could surge so that's
part of it they're worried about how the
impact of this virus could have on
hospitals could surge up to nineteen
thousand five hundred patients which is
well beyond capacity again this is a
developing story and we'll we'll keep
our eyes on it right now Laura back to
you Jeff thanks so much that was
absolutely a drastic order but it looks
like they're gonna be locked down for
some time in California thanks so much